what could possibly be happier than a
swim in the Frozen Waters of the North
Atlantic breathe in through the nose and
out
how did I get here let's find out
I grew up as a big-headed baby in
Seattle
eventually I landed in Los Angeles as
assistant to the regional manager yet
for All My Success you'd think I'd be
happier
oh
but like so many others I struggle wow
to find true Joy I have been diagnosed
with an anxiety disorder like I am a
highly anxious person happiness is out
there hiding in some of the places you'd
least expect what I want to know is
which places
[Music]
how much of our happiness is a matter of
perspective you don't need all the
material things to be happy
thanks so much
to understand happiness I'll need to
embrace what comes my way why do this
because you can
in Los Angeles we barely know the people
that we live near here everybody's
family
[Music]
Icelandic way he really struck our
trunks
[Music]